like christmas exploded on my face
action
hey i'm shahiri recipe developer here at
tasty and today we're going to ring in
the holiday season with my world famous
white chocolate snowball truffles that
we're going to use to build the most
majestic holiday dessert wreath you're
gonna love it but before we get started
i mean we need a little festive spirit
around here
ah that's more like it we've got
everything we need to make our white
chocolate snowball truffles and it
begins with a pot of gently simmering
water i'm gonna put a large bowl right
on top of that pot and then we're gonna
add our white chocolate 12 ounces or 340
grams
right into the bowl a third cup of cream
heavy whipping cream 35 full fat and two
tablespoons of butter and we're going to
let this melt over the pot of simmering
water well white chocolate gets a bad
wrap sometimes because it's not
technically chocolate
tastes good though there's the last
pocket of butter there mix it all
beautifully together look how nice it
looks but now we've got this beautiful
white chocolate
base and we're going to add the holiday
spices and a little bit of orange zest
to make it super festive got a quarter
teaspoon of cinnamon and then we're
going to go in with just 8 8 of a
teaspoon of nutmeg you don't want too
much it's just there in the background
mix it all together into the ganache and
then
orange zest lots of flavor in the zest
make sure you wash your orange and then
zest it
right into the ganache
and you'll smell it right away
get it into your ganache and then
like any good dessert should have a
pinch of salt you want to wake up all
these flavors not too much
mix it all together now we just put in
the fridge you want to firm it up for an
hour and a half to two hours so it's
that nice firm consistency that we can
shape stuff with jam roll up and form
as you can see our white chocolate
ganache has firmed up nicely and this is
the consistency you want i mean you
could really put it
you see
firm
now we're going to divide it into evenly
shaped balls an ice cream scooper
is good for this
and this batch will make about 14 to 16
truffles okay we've got 14 evenly sized
little pieces and now i'd like to stuff
it with a little bit of jam so with your
finger put an indent in the center of
your piece and just put a dollop i've
got raspberry jam because i like that
pop of red
but you could do also orange marmalade
to play with that orange zest in your
truffle and then just kind of close it
up if a little bit gets out it's okay
and then in your hands
roll it nice circular shape right into
the coconut
unsweetened coconut i think the jam and
the white chocolate is sweet enough for
sure and there you go
okay
last truffle is done we're gonna pop
these in the fridge to firm up a bit and
then we're gonna start building our
festive dessert wreath
[Music]
okay let's see what we've got here for
the rest of our festive dessert wreath
ingredients
we've got to have the holiday chocolates
of course
come on
i've got the frerro's let's see what
else we got here ah deluxe nuts i like a
little salty with the sweet okay we've
got a lot of good stuff here let's grab
those truffles and we'll start to build
our festive dessert reef
[Music]
tada
our beautiful white chocolate snowball
truffles look at these things they're
cool and now we're gonna start to
assemble and there's no rules here i
mean have fun with it just make sure
that things are evenly distributed all
this stuff by the way the ingredients
the lights the decorations i got from
walmart so walmart really is your
one-stop shop for everything holiday
this year check it out now we start to
build with the star of the show our
truffles that we made and it's okay if
some of the coconut gets everywhere
because it's kind of like the snow
here we go
what do you think
there you have it ladies and gentlemen
the ultimate festive dessert wreath
complete with our very own homemade
white chocolate snowball truffles
click on the link below to get the
recipe for these amazing white chocolate
snowball truffles and get the tips to
design your very own holiday dessert
wreath happy holidays
oh yes
i'm very good at snapping as you can see
now this one
not so much but this one